Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Es ist März, aufregend.
Ja, es ist sehr viel passiert in den letzten Tagen. Wir müssen also über den Iran sprechen unbedingt. Aber zuvor möchte ich etwas korrigieren und ergänzen. Denn ich habe hier mal behauptet vor, ich glaube, zwei Ausgaben und da gab es einige E-Mails dazu, die das korrigiert haben, dass es für russische Studenten, wenn sie in Deutschland studieren, so sein muss, dass sie da ein Sperrkonto haben mit etwa 12.000 Euro drauf, woraufhin man mir sagte, ja, das stimmt. Aber das gilt für alle Nicht-EU-Studenten, die müssen ein solches Sperrkonto haben. Daraufhin habe ich aber noch mal nachgefragt, was ist jetzt die spezifische Problematik bei den russischen Studenten, die hier studieren wollen, die also auch dann nicht in der Heimat sein wollen. Habe also bei der besagten Studentin und ihrem Freund nachgefragt, mit denen ich gesprochen habe. Und die haben mir eine lange E-Mail geschrieben. Und da bin ich sehr dankbar, denn es ist schon interessant, wie das geregelt ist. Ohne festen Wohnsitz in der EU ist es für russische Staatsangehörige nämlich kaum möglich, ein Konto bei einer Bank in der EU zu eröffnen. Natürlich reichen keine russischen Bankkonten, weil von der EU aus kein Zugriff möglich ist. Das heißt, diese Schwierigkeit haben die schon. Für alle russischen Studierenden, die ein Bachelorstudium beginnen wollen und noch nie in Russland studiert haben, ist der Besuch eines Studienkollegs erforderlich. Hierfür ist zudem eine vorherige Aufnahmeprüfung vor Ort in Deutschland zu absolvieren. Und hierfür ist es schwierig, ein Visum zu erhalten. Drittstaatler außerhalb der EU, also auch Russen, mit kurzem Aufenthalt dürfen nur für wenige Tage ein Visum bekommen, für die Zeit der Prüfung zum Studienkolleg quasi, da ja kein bestehender Prüfung garantiert werden kann. Danach ist eine sofortige Abreise wieder erforderlich. Um ein Sperrkonto zu öffnen, müssen sie also quasi parallel zur Prüfung eine Wohnung finden, sich bei den Behörden melden, Post bekommen und dann ein Sperrkonto eröffnen. Alles innerhalb von wenigen Tagen. Bei kurzen Visa ist der Kontakt mit der Bundespolizei auch hin und wieder schwierig, steht hier. Grundsätzlich gelten für Russen erschwerte Bedingungen für Visa-Anträge durch Beschluss des Europäischen Rats infolge des Krieges. Mehr dazu auf der Website der Deutschen Botschaft. Dann kommen sie mit einer persönlichen Anekdote, wo jetzt keine Allgemeingültigkeit drin liegen muss, sagen sie. Ein russischer Freund hat die Erfahrung gemacht, dass Zeugnisse aus Russland kaum oder gar nicht anerkannt werden. Es handelte sich um einen fast abgeschlossenen Bachelorabschluss in Pharmazie. Dieser musste daher das Studienkolleg vollständig absolvieren und von vorne anfangen. Grundsätzlich bestehen große Schwierigkeiten mittels Flüge aus Moskau und Russland in die EU einzureisen. Außerdem besteht keine Möglichkeit, Geld aus Russland in die EU zu überweisen, sodass eine finanzielle Unterstützung des Studiums, zum Beispiel durch die Familie, verunmöglicht wird. Dann noch ein Hinweis allgemein zu dem Sperrkonto. Um überhaupt ein Visum beantragen zu können, muss ein Kontostand von mindestens 11.904 Euro verpflichtend nachgewiesen werden. Monatlich dürfen dann von diesem Konto maximal 992 Euro auf ein, in Anführungszeichen, normales Konto überwiesen werden. Und nach einem Jahr muss allerdings zur Verlängerung des Visums wieder der Kontostand, der alte, wieder da sein, 11.904 Euro, aufgrund der oben angesprochenen erschwerten finanziellen Bedingungen und der ausbleibenden Unterstützung durch Angehörige, stellt dies für russische Studierende ein besonderes Problem dar. Einen BAföG-Anspruch haben russische Studierende im Gegensatz zu ukrainischen Studierenden auch nicht. Diejenigen Russen, die es in die EU geschafft haben, bekommen keinen offiziellen Flüchtlingsstatus anerkannt. Ausnahmen bestehen lediglich bei politischen Asylstatus. Die Anerkennungsquote für russische Deserteure und Wehrpflichtige ist hier übrigens sehr gering. Asyl kann natürlich auch nur in Deutschland vor Ort beantragt werden. Zusammengefasst ist es so gut wie unmöglich, als Russe oder Russin in die EU nach 22 einzureisen und anschließend zu studieren. Wir reden ja viel über Manpower, über Fachkräftemangel, darüber, dass Putin auch einen Krieg gegen die Demografie führt bzw. von vorher her getrieben ist. Wir könnten also Putin erheblich schwächen, wenn ich mir mal dieses Wir anmaßen möchte. Wir werden ja heute noch zu Rikke Herrmann kommen, da haben wir ja ganz viel von diesem Wir. Also es ist ein Wahnsinn, dass man nicht sagt, toll, wir nehmen jetzt die Leute hier ab und die leben hier ein ganz anderes Leben. Nein, man erschwert es ihnen. Man lässt sie dort, damit sie Kanonenfutter bleiben. Die haben dann noch hier angemerkt, noch mal komplizierter wird es dann für Doppelstaatler, denn da gibt es ja Vorschläge im Sondierungspapier von CSU und SPD, dass man diese doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft bei Russen aufgibt, was dann bedeutet, die müssten sich hier entscheiden, dann müssten also dann die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft annehmen. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja ist doch gut, warum, die wollen doch eh nicht in Russland sein. Das bedeutet für die dann aber auch eine Gängelung seitens Russlands, beziehungsweise für einige wird es so aussehen, dass sie dann keine Chance mehr haben, in Russland mal wieder ihre Familie zu sehen. Wenn sie diesen Pass aufgegeben haben, den russischen, dann ist das ein klares Statement für Russland. Und ich habe auch eine Anekdote, die ich jetzt nicht hier weiter erzählen will, aus dem Konsulat gehört, wie da dann umgegangen wird mit den Doppelstaatlern, die eher nach Deutschland tendieren als nach Russland. Insofern ist das eine Situation, die eigentlich untragbar ist und würde man den Menschen helfen, würde man jedenfalls Putin auch schaden.
Ja, das ist natürlich, ich würde auch sagen, der Brain Drain ist ja das, was Putin am meisten fürchtet. Und das, was wir offenbar am meisten ihm noch zugestehen. Die Leute dürfen nicht hierher. Und die Frage ist ja, wollen wir nicht, dass die klugen Leute, die ein Land tragen können, mit dem man einen Start machen kann, hierherkommen? Und jetzt hast du den Umgang mit Russen erzählt. Hier in Hessen, ich hatte ja mich mehrfach jetzt schon darüber beklagt, dass das hessische Bildungskultusministerium gesagt hat, 70 Millionen müssen an den hessischen Schulen gestrichen werden. Also alle außer Gymnasien natürlich.
Natürlich.
Was bedeutet, es wird wieder so eine kalkulierte Verdummung stattfinden. Nun hat das SPD-Wirtschaftsministerium angeboten, diesen Betrag auszugleichen. Also einfach von einem Ministerium zum nächsten zu überweisen, hat natürlich eine Koalitionskrise ausgelöst. Boris Rhein hat sich am Ende durchgesetzt, die Koalition bleibt bestehen, aber dieses Geld fließt nicht. Also nicht nur halten wir kluge Russen raus, sondern wir wollen auch keine klugen Deutschen. Es sind wirklich harte Umstände. Von daher hier ein kleiner Nachtrag. Ich habe jetzt in der Februar-Folge, weil sie so voll war, ganz meine Männer und Frauen des Monats vergessen. Das sind natürlich all diese Kommunalpolitiker in Verantwortung, die unter diesen schweren Umständen von Land und Bund einfach komplett veralbert zu werden, trotzdem Stadt regieren. Um es mal so drastisch zu sagen. Also es gibt einen Krieg, der brach los, nachdem wir den Podcast gerade verendet und hochgeladen hatten, weshalb uns einige schrieben, hättet ihr noch einen Tag gewartet, hättet ihr das mitbehandeln können. Und mein erster Gedanke war so, na was hätten wir denn am Tag eins dazu sagen können, außer das übliche, wie auch immer. So, wir richten uns ja, also wir interessieren uns für die Weltlage, aber wir richten uns ja nicht in unserem Rhythmus nach ihr. Stellt sich raus, mein Gedanke war nicht so ganz richtig oder nicht ganz plausibel, denn mittlerweile ist es alles so platt, dass man tatsächlich fünf Stunden, nachdem man sich die Nachrichtenlage angeschaut hat, einfach wirklich ein Fazit ziehen kann. Es ist wirklich alles ganz einfach gestrickt und ich möchte daran erinnern, bevor wir drei Clips zum Iran spielen aus The Daily, um uns das einfach nur zu verdeutlichen, wie das in Venezuela war. Denn das geschah ja auch so am Monatsanfang, so dass wir am Monatsende gar nicht so richtig dazu kamen. Also habe ich noch mal meine Notizen rausgekramt. Am 3. Januar gab es diese Militäroperation Nightfall. Also die fliegen darüber, haben das vorher sondiert, geprobt an Nachbauten von dem Haus, wie auch immer, und haben dann Maduro entführt. Dann gab es diese Machtübernahme durch Rodriguez, die Vizepräsidentin. Während hier in Deutschland noch Kommentare geschrieben worden zum Thema, das ist voll gut, dass der Maduro weg ist, denn das war ein ganz schwieriger Typ und wir sind auch gegenschwierige Typen.
Und jetzt kommt Demokratie da.
Genau. Man mag hier über Trump sagen, was man will, aber er hat zumindest da mal aufgeräumt.
Ja. Übrigens ja von den Leuten, man muss das sich wirklich ansehen. Also diese Ecke Strack Zimmermann und Co., die ist ja gerade auf so einem Trip, wir müssen uns eigentlich sehr emanzipieren, wir starken Europäer und all das. Und dann sagen sie aber, sobald dann doch irgendetwas geschieht, was Trump macht, was sie wieder gut finden. Ja, nee, da ist er ja noch auf der richtigen Seite. Wir haben zum Teil Leute, die sagen, Trump ist ein Protofaschist oder ein Faschist. Und sie sagen zugleich, wie gut, dass jetzt Trump das autoritäre Regime in Iran absetzt, damit dort Demokratie stattfinden kann. Wir sehen einen Präsidenten, und wir sehen ja auch noch einen anderen Präsidenten, wir sehen Netanyahu, die beide die Demokratie bekämpfen, wo sie nur können. Und zugleich sagen diese Leute, wie gut, dass Netanyahu und Trump Demokratie in die Welt bringen, vor allem jetzt im Iran.
Genau, und all diese Kommentatoren wurden wirklich hart Lügen gestraft, denn sie wussten es eigentlich auch besser, und es hat sich ja dann in wenigen Tagen entfaltet. Denn es gab dieses Ultimatum der US-Regierung, die maximale Kontrolle wird jetzt über Venezuela, wir regieren hier wie auch immer, es sei denn, irgendwas begibt sich in Venezuela. Und das hat ja die Machado, die Nobelpreisträgerin, zum Anlass genommen zu sagen, ich fahre jetzt dahin und guck mal, wie meine Chancen sind. Denn bei so einer Großwetterlage, wenn in westlichen Zeitungen steht, die mich gerade zu Gast hatten, weil ich aber hier den Nobelpreis in Europa angenommen, dass hier vielleicht Unterstützung für alternative Regime da sind, dann nutze ich diese Chance. Und sie ist natürlich dort einfach keinen Meter vorwärts gekommen. Stattdessen wurde die Rodriguez vereidigt. Und dann gab es genau einen Tag lang Stress mit Trump über öffentliche Meinungsbekundungen, von der ich sage, abgesprochen wie zwischen DGB und SPD, wenn irgendeine Sache passiert. Und dann gab es dieses Treffen im Weißen Haus am 15. Januar, bei dem sie ihren Nobelpreis übergibt. Also durch die nachrichtliche Großwetterlage, Europa, westliche Welt, zum Glück ist der Maduro weg, zum Glück jetzt Regime Change, der Bevölkerung, dort geht es ganz schlecht. Hat sie gedacht, sie nutzt jetzt die Chance und hat die dümmste Aktion des Jahrhunderts gemacht, nämlich ihren Nobelpreis an ein Handlanger des Regimes, an den Schirmherren, den neuen Schirmherren des Regimes zu schenken. So und im Zuge dieser Sache hören wir jetzt diese drei Iran-Clips, die New York Times und deswegen spielen wir es jetzt und am Monatsende mal gucken, was vom Thema übrig bleibt. Aber es war tatsächlich einfach am Tag eins klar, die New York Times hat es so deutlich gemacht mittlerweile, dass man sich auch, da würde ich jetzt wieder sagen, also Trump ist ja wirklich ein ganz fieser, schlechter Mensch und ein schlechter Präsident, aber dass er den Journalismus wieder dazu führt, seine eigentliche Aufgabe wahrzunehmen, ist voll gut. Solche Leitartikel würde ich jetzt schreiben.
Nur leider hier nicht so stark.
Leider hier nicht so stark, aber in Amerika ist es ein bisschen anders.
Denn wir haben es ja mit der New York Times, mit einer linksliberalen Zeitung zu tun, die jetzt an sich...
Da werden aber einige jetzt eine linksliberale Zeitung... Also liberal, ja. Die New York Times ist aber nicht...
Na ja, also mit linksliberal meine ich jetzt so Mitte, Mitte, Mitte, links. Also nicht links, so wie ich jetzt links verstehe.
Die New York Times publiziert zu jedem gängigen Suchbegriff, den man gerade in Nachrichtenlage hat, pro Stunde fünf Artikel. Du kannst auch eine ganz andere New York Times lesen, wir sehen.
Ist mir völlig egal, was ich nur damit sagen will, das ist keine radikal linke Zeitung.
Ach so, genau, ja genau.
Also das ist nicht Jacobin. Das sind nicht Anti-Imperialisten. Das sind sehr patriotische Autoren aus einer linken, verfassungsdemokratischen Auffassung heraus. Da gibt es auch konservative Stimme, ich weiß das alles. Was ich nur sagen will, wir sind hier im Mainstream. Wenn wir jetzt in den deutschen Mainstream blicken, dann hören wir genau diese Töne. Ich kenne die Töne noch nicht, aber ich würde jetzt schon mal prognostizieren, die hören wir hier nicht. Und das ist das Verrückte. Hier musst du zu Jacobin etc. gehen, musst du bei Neue Deutschland noch mal nachlesen. Und hier haben wir im Mainstream der amerikanischen Newsfabrik genau die Äußerungen, die wir hier ja vergeblich irgendwo im Mainstream suchen.
Genau, hier muss man eh noch mal eine neue Distinktion einführen irgendwie. Es gibt den Mainstream und dann gibt es so den Mainstream. Aber es ist nicht so der innere Mainstream, sondern es ist der Mainstream der Masse. Und dann gibt es den Mainstream der wenigen, aber die wenigen Tonangebenden.
Ja.
Also da, wo Morgenlagen bereitet werden, wo man noch eine Zeitung liest und so und sich nicht nur beschallen lässt. Genau. Wir sind jetzt in diesem inneren Minority Mainstream sozusagen, der aber über lang jetzt im Mittel bis langfristigen Ton angebend ist, aber nicht im Tagesaktuellen, sondern da ist Fox News und der ganze Kram. Und da hören wir diese drei Clips. Zum einen, das finde ich jetzt nur inhaltlich auch sehr interessant. Was ist mit Kamini? Warum hat er sich einfach totschießen lassen? Und es ist genau so von mir jetzt gefragt.
Und was viele iranische Offiziere jetzt sagen, ist, dass Mr. Kamini nicht mehr sein Zuhause und sein Komponent und hat den Leuten um ihn herum gesagt, dass, wenn er sich in den Krieg startet, er eher ein Widerstander werden würde. Ich denke, dass in seinem Geist seine Legasie besser geschützt werden würde, als jemand, der nicht in den Krieg steigt, nicht Angst hat, wobei, wenn er das Geist der Venezuelas, Nicolas Maduro, erzielt würde, oder wenn sein Regime zerstört würde, wäre er verhämtet.
Hat er sich einfach aufgegeben? 86 Jahre, fast 50 Jahre an der Macht? Hat er gesagt, es reicht?
Es gab von El Hotso so einen Tweet, der hätte ja eh nur noch ein, zwei Jahre gelebt, so ich paraphrasiere jetzt. Und jetzt haben die dem noch das Geschenk gemacht, dass er Märtyrer werden kann. Und jetzt hören wir das im Prinzip hier.
Es ist ein ganz ernsthafter Gedanke.
Na ja, gut, das ist ein nur ein fanatischer Mensch, wie wir wussten und wissen. Und dann leuchtet das sehr ein.
Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, im Zuge einer Diskussion, in der wir Milliardäre auch nachher wieder nur unter Longevity, ewig maximale Macht und so weiter diskutieren.
Na ja, die sind ja, wenn sie zum Himmel blicken, da ist dann nicht viel. Aber diese traditionell fanatischen Gläubigen, die sagen dann, na ja, da wird ja schon auf mich gewartet.
Also das ist wirklich, fand ich wahnsinnig interessant. So und jetzt die beiden Clips. Also wir haben es ausreichend vorbereitet.
Wir wundern uns ja sowieso, dass die Iran angegriffen wird, weil wir doch vor ein paar Monaten schon mal diese Angriff hatten. Und dann hatte doch Trump uns gesagt, dass alles zerstört wurde. Und zwar auf Jahrzehnte, soweit ich mich recht erinnere.
Ja, das hat man natürlich im Fernsehpodcast juxend zur Geltung gebracht, wie das thematisiert wurde. Aber genau, es sollte doch alles obliviated sein. Nun, während die deutschen Kommentatoren ihre Texte noch nicht mal angefangen haben zu schreiben, wie schlimm das im Iran ist, und zum Glück ist es Regimewecker, New York Times.
Ist es, Farnas, ein Leader im Regime, den USA, den Israel, vielleicht tolerabel finden, den sie als jemand sehen, der in Theorie zu dem, was im Regime bleibt, sein Leid, möglicherweise zu der Opposition zu sein, und den USA, Israel und ihre Leaders können damit etwas tun.
Das ist die Art von Person, die die USA in Venezuela gefunden hat, nachdem es Nicolás Maduro verletzt hat.
Es ist interessant, dass du Venezuela aufhörst, weil iranische Gründer mir sagen, dass eine der Gespräche, die sie in private haben, über Succession und über Planung, zwischen sich selbst, die Frage ist, wer der Delsi von Iran sein wird, die Venezuelas Vizepräsidenten nennen. Einige der Namen, die hierher kommen, sind Technikraten und Ex-General der Revolutionärgärten, die als Zentristen, Pragmatisten, Menschen sind, die vielleicht offen sind, zu einem Veränderungskurs zu führen. Einer der Namen ist Ali Laridoni, Ich bin die Heirin des National Security Councils, der jetzt effektiv das Land runnend ist.
Ganz normale Politik. Die rufen quasi an und fragen, wer aus der Nationalgarde kann denn jetzt hier? Und es ist tatsächlich Chefsache, ja. Also Trump selbst ist es ein Anliegen.
Das sind einige der Namen, die ich gehört habe. Aber ich möchte hier erwähnen, dass für diesen 80 Prozent, Die wollen eine wunderschöne Veränderung und für die Opposition eine Verletzung. Keine Figur, die mit dem islamischen Regime vertreten wird, wird akzeptabel werden. Denn jeder einer dieser Menschen war ein Teil eines Systems und hatte eine Rolle in diesen Oppressionen und Tötungen und Repressionen, die seit 47 Jahren ein Teil dieses Regimes waren. Aber die Frage ist, ob die USA und Präsident Trump letztlich entscheiden werden, dass er keine Risiken für die Stabilität in Iran, keine Risiken für die Zivilwahl haben will, und eher mit jemanden aus dem System der sich eine Konzession machen will oder nicht. Wir haben heute von Präsident Trump gehört, dass er offen ist, mit den neuen Iranierenden zu sprechen. Er hat gehört, dass es einige Optionen für eine Konzession gibt. Ich denke, er signaliert den iranischen Regime, dass wenn man einen Charakter hat, der sich will, was er will, und die Konzessionen, die er will, auf nukleare und militärische Missile und Polizistinnen...
Dann werde ich diesen Leader zurückführen.
Wenn ich ihn nicht zurückführen werde, dann werde ich ihn entgegen und entzündet, die Möglichkeit dieser Leader zu haben.
So dreht sich das Autokratenkarussell weiter. Da geht es nicht um die Befreiung der Bevölkerung. Es war ja sowieso lustig, dass Trump dann sowas sagte wie und jetzt muss das iranische Volk aufstehen, aber bleiben sie bitte zu Hause, damit sie nicht von den Bomben getroffen werden. Also das funktioniert natürlich alles vorne und hinten nicht. Dass man uns das hier immer noch einredet und auch Leute bereit sind, das zu glauben. Was muss denn Trump noch machen, dass man dann davon mal abrückt? Also ich verstehe das gar nicht. Wie ist das möglich? Also wenn das jetzt der wohlmeinende Präsident wäre von früher, der das freundliche Gesicht gezeigt hätte und das noch bemäntelt hätte, dann würde ich sagen, naja, da sind manche zu naiv oder wir haben natürlich auch viele Leute, die es glauben wollen. Aber das hier ist ja nun jetzt so offenbar, dass man auch sagen muss, wer da das Gegenteil behauptet, lügt. Anders ist es überhaupt nicht auszudrücken.
Also die Zeit hatte, ich habe mir extra einen Screenshot gemacht, weil es ungewöhnlich war, einen Aufmacher als Kommentar auf die Seite genommen. Dieser Angriff ist ein großes Unrecht für den Krieg gegen den Iran, hat Donald Trump keine Gründe und keinen Plan, die folgen wird, Europa spüren. Umso fataler, wie sich die Bundesregierung weckduckt. Es war wirklich der einzige Text, der mal in die Richtung geht. Ich habe den jetzt konkret nicht gelesen, sondern mir nur den Skitchart gemacht am Morgen.
In unseren Mainstream-Podcasts, die wir jetzt nicht alle hier wieder erwähnen, eigentlich nur Propaganda für diese Sache. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das rechtfertigen kann, wie das möglich ist, dass man auch glaubt, dass man nach wie vor diese Erzählweise fortsetzen kann, wo ich auch sagen muss, naja, so doof ist ja wirklich niemand, das noch zu glauben.
Eigentlich nicht, es ist wirklich verrückt. Ich möchte einen soziologischen Hinweis, weil wir ja immer die Frage hatten, wie stabilisiert man überhaupt so eine Diktatur? Da steht einer an der Spitze, wie Putin oder so, und ist ganz in Land gehorcht. Wie funktioniert das? Und dann hören wir immer den Standard, ja, Medien ausschalten, Gerichte auf Kurs bringen, wie wir es in Polen gesehen haben. Also das droht sozusagen überall. Aber die Frage ist ja wirklich konkret, wie gelingt es? Und im Iran ist es ganz offensichtlich und für alle sichtbar beantwortet, diese Frage. Und das haben wir auch zuletzt durch diese Massaker gesehen. Denn es ist nicht schon lange nicht mehr zentral gesteuert, dieses religiös irgendwie aufgeputschte Regime von alten Leuten, die irgendwas wollen. Also die schaffen es nicht, 40.000 Leute totzuschießen, sondern das Prinzip läuft über diese Nationalgarde, die das Land längst regiert oder sich aufgeteilt hat, wie so eine Mafia auf jeder Straße ein Profitinteresse einfach manifestiert.
Wie in Indien. Ich will jetzt nicht Indien mit dem Iran vergleichen, aber in Indien sehen wir auch, wie solche paramilitärischen Strukturen von Modi immer weiter aufgebaut wurden, die ihm erst den Erfolg gesichert haben. Und dann haben die irgendwann ja eine eigene unternehmerische Tätigkeit im Land und sorgen dafür, dass alle auf Spur bleiben und haben unglaubliche Spielräume, sich selbst zu ermächtigen und zu handeln und brutal Aufstände oder Dissidenz niederzuschlagen.
So, und das bedeutet aber, wir haben es hier mit 10.000 involvierten Menschen zu tun, bewaffnet, die alle, also die haben einen ordentlichen Rekrutierungsapparat. Da kannst du jetzt nicht einfach in Teheran jemanden wegschießen und dann 200 Kilometer weit entfernen, sagt dann jemanden, oh ja, okay, dann machen wir jetzt Demokratie oder so. Sondern die kämpfen jetzt alle für sich um diese Vorherrschaft. Von daher ist dieses Regime-Change anliegend sowieso und von jemandem wie Donald Trump, der seinen Truppen noch, und das ist auch eine interessante Parallele, angeblich wurde ja den Militärs jetzt gesagt, hier geht es um Armageddon, also die Ermöglichung der Wiederkunft Christi. Wir haben das hier ausführlich thematisiert, wo diese Ideen herkommen und wie die auch in deutschen Podcasts so thematisiert werden. Und langsam stellt sich auch die Frage, ich hatte es ja bei Venezuela schon kurz aufgeworfen, warum fand denn für den Irak-Krieg so ein großes mediales, die UN, Colin Powell, erzählt er irgendwas von Massenvernichtungswaffen? Wir haben immer gedacht, das ist für uns, für die öffentliche Meinung. Nein, das ist, damit die Soldaten, die konkret schießen, zu Hause sagen können, ich habe es für die Demokratie getan. So, zum zweiten Mal jetzt, innerhalb eines Jahres, müssen diese Soldaten zu Hause sich anders rechtfertigen, weil sie dieses Angebot nicht mehr haben. Beim ersten Mal hat Trump selber gesagt, mir geht es hier ums Öl. Was bedeutet, wenn man zu Weihnachten als Soldat nach Hause kehrt, ist es, du hast hier fürs Öl den Weg frei geschossen. Nein, für die Demokratie. Das habe ich aber anders gehört bei meinem Präsidenten. Ja, und wenn jetzt aus Öl...
Und warum ist das Öl jetzt gerade so teuer? Naja, das war, weil wir da auch im Iran waren. Da war wieder anders.
Ja, genau. Und wenn jetzt im Iran plötzlich die Soldaten sich eben eins zu eins, im privaten eins zu eins, plötzlich mit Armageddon und Jesus Christ rumschlagen müssen. Also das ist einfach, also hier lodert noch eine ganz andere Sache vor sich. Aber dazu werden wir keinen deutschen Text bekommen. Wir haben häufiger die Frage, warum wir so, gerade ich so viel New York Times lese, weil da halt so was thematisiert wird. Aber in den Deutschen einfach gar nicht, nirgendwo. Also ich wüsste jetzt keine Zeitung.
Ich habe dir jetzt ein Clip mitgepasst, Stefan. Wir haben natürlich auch unsere News. Ich habe gedacht, ich bin ja ein einfacher Mensch. Lass es mir doch mal wie für ein Kind erklären. Hat mir das ZDF-Logo angesehen. Dort war Armin Laschet im Interview und dem wurden Fragen gestellt von jungen Zuschauern, die wissen wollten, wie geht es denn da jetzt weiter. Wir haben jetzt ja in der vergangenen Folge ausführlich über das Social-Media-Verbot geredet und wir wissen, eine Argumentation seitens der Politik ist, die jungen Leute geraten im Netz an Fake News und die müssen sich richtig informieren können, Medienkompetenz. Deswegen ist das besser, wenn sie dann nicht einfach so irgendwo hinein geraten. Deswegen habe ich gedacht, dann informieren wir uns doch ganz richtig quasi hochoffiziell. ZDF und Armin Laschet, wir hören da mal rein.
Wissen, wie lange der Krieg voraussichtlich noch dauert und ob es Gründe gibt, warum sich der Krieg noch quasi in die Länge schien könnte?
Das kann im Moment gar niemand sagen, wie lange der Krieg dauern wird. Die Schätzungen der Amerikaner waren in den letzten Tagen vielleicht vier Wochen, aber vielleicht geht es auch schneller. Keiner kann das im Moment sagen. Wir müssen uns alle wünschen, dass der Krieg schnell zu Ende geht, so schnell wie möglich und dass die Menschen im Iran dann selbst bestimmen können, wer sie regiert, dass sie eine Demokratie werden, wo auch die jungen Leute eine Chance haben.
Die jungen Leute, darum geht es eigentlich, die Demokratie. So wird hier informiert. Noch eine Frage an Armin Laschet. Herr Laschet zum Schluss. Das ist übrigens der Moderator von ZDF Logo, der auch diese herrliche Sendung machte, in der Kinder gefragt wurden, willst du zu Militär? Ja oder ja? Wir hatten diese Sache. Jetzt noch der kurze Blick nach vorne. Pauline hat uns folgende Frage zugeschickt. Gibt es schon Ideen, Frieden zu schließen?
Das kann man im Moment noch nicht sagen. Es gibt Ideen, was passiert, wenn der Krieg zu Ende ist. Dann soll der Iran wieder aufgebaut werden. Dann sollen alle die, die im Moment unterdrückt sind, ein neues, freies Land aufbauen.
Wo gibt es diese Idee?
Also ich habe sogar noch eine andere Idee gesehen. Da stand Strackzimmermann mit Reza Pahlavi da und wollte uns auch noch signalisieren, vielleicht ist das auch eine Option. Also geht es doch ohne Demokratie.
Ich würde sagen, das korrespondiert ganz wunderbar mit diesen 70 Millionen raus aus den Schulen.
Ja. Wo jeder auch nach seiner Vorstellung leben kann, aber wie jetzt man zu einem Frieden kommt, das kann man jetzt nach dem Zwei-Tage-Erst-der-Krieg begonnen hat, noch nicht sagen. Das Ziel muss jedenfalls sein, so schnell wie möglich. Und das Ergebnis muss auch sein, der Iran darf keine Atombomben mehr bauen können, denn das bedroht uns und das bedroht auch viele andere.
Herr Laschet, vielen Dank für das Gespräch. Es sieht schon hälzlich aus. Ja. Also da sagen ja nun jetzt auch hier gestandene Experten, dass mit den Atombomben dabei jetzt nichts in absehbarer Zeit zu befürchten. Es ist unglaublich. Deswegen brauchen wir unbedingt eine Debatte. Brauchen wir ein ZDF-Logo-Verbot? Wie schützen wir unsere Kinder vor ZDF-Logo? Braucht man da vielleicht eine Altersverifikation? Das sollte man dringend jetzt mal starten, diese Debatte. Völkerrecht ist ja so eine Angelegenheit, auf die man sich gerne beruht, bezieht, wenn es einem hilft. Wir haben das gesehen. Wir sehen Völkerrechtsbrüche bei Putin. Deshalb gibt es auch diese entsprechenden Reaktionen aus dem Westen. Wir sehen aber jetzt gerade die, die besonders auf das Völkerrecht beharrt haben, wie Roderich Kiesewetter und andere, die sagen, naja gut, hier ist das ja ein anderer Fall, weil es ja gar keine Demokratie ist. Aber das Völkerrecht gilt ja auch dann. Es ist eben nicht ein Völkerrecht, das interveniert, wo immer, keine Demokratie ist, weil dann könnte man permanent intervenieren. Eine Frage ist dann von der Perspektive. Und dann sagt natürlich aus einer Putin-Perspektive heraus Putin, ja, wieso soll ich mich denn als Völkerrecht erhalten? Ihr tut es ja sowieso auch nicht, wie wir hier sehen können. Aber man sieht, mal ist das Völkerrecht sinnvoll, mal ist es nicht sinnvoll. Es gibt aber auch noch Stimmen in Europa, die tatsächlich sich auf das Völkerrecht beziehen und auch klare Kante da machen gegenüber Trump bzw. auch sich ja scheuen, diese EU-Aufrüstungsstrategien mitzugehen. Wir wissen, Spanien stellt sich da quer. Die sagen, dass sie dieses 3,5 Prozent Ziel NATO nicht erreichen wollen. Sie haben andere Aufgaben, um die sie sich kümmern müssen, zum Beispiel Bildung, da wird nicht irgendwas gespart. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal den Ministerpräsidenten von Spanien an, Pedro Sanchez. Wir hören ihn jetzt mal im Original, weil ich zu gerne Spanisch höre. Aber dann hören wir die Übersetzungsanlage. Nein, aber ich finde, das klingt immer so schön.
Wir sind in einer sehr gefährlichen Art fliegend in einen immer mehr unstaublichen, unverstärkenden, und deshalb mehr unvergesslicher Art fliegend, für die Menschen der Mörder.
Gestern, glaube ich, haben diese Angst wieder bemerkt, leider.
Zwei Länder haben unilaterale Angriffe auf Iran, die USA und Israel, ohne die internationale Gemeinde zu haben.
Man kann gegen einen wütenden Regime stehen, wie das Gesamt von der Spanischen Gesellschaft.
Ja, was sagt er hier? Er sagte, wir stehen vor einer sehr gefährlichen Ära. Die Welt wird instabiler, unsicherer, schneller und damit für die Normalbürger ungerechter. Gestern haben sich diese Befürchtung meiner Meinung nach leider erneut bestätigt. Zwei Länder, die Vereinigten Staaten und Israel, haben den Iran einseitig angegriffen, ohne die internationale Gemeinschaft einzubeziehen. Man kann gegen ein verabscheuungswürdiges Regime sein, wie es die gesamte spanische Gesellschaft gegenüber dem iranischen Regime ist. Und gleichzeitig gegen eine ungerechtfertigte, gefährliche und völkerrechtswidrige militärische Intervention sein. Man kann gegen einen Krieg sein, der ohne die Zustimmung des US-Kongresses und des UN-Sicherheitsrates begonnen wurde. Und wie ich bereits sagte, gegen das Völkerrecht verstößt. Und es gibt immer Raum für eine Verhandlungslösung, anstatt sich von der Zerstörung durch Waffen als einzigem Ausweg mitreißen zu lassen. Das sind kluge Worte. Es ist skandalös.
Können wir uns als Spanisch lesen lassen?
Wie?
Naja, immer wieder revitalisieren, diese Idee, dass man seine Identität so ein bisschen selbst gestaltet.
Ja.
Und ich möchte mich gerne, es ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass wir aus Spanien jetzt Sachen hören. Plötzlich werden eine halbe Million nicht Spanier ein-europäisiert. Man wendet sich gegen das 5%-NATO-Ziel.
Man wendet sich auch gegen diese Austenitätspolitik. Man hat investiert während dieser Krise, während hier alles dümpelte.
Ich wäre gerne in Spanien.
Ja, ich auch. Ich habe sehr unter diesem Winter gelitten. Es war ja doch wirklich schrecklich. Und Spanien wäre da noch eine Möglichkeit. Ich denke, wir sollten das mal erproben. Vielleicht machen wir... Ach so. Ja, ja, Moment. Dann könnten wir zumindest nach Gran Canaria. Denn da ist ja immer angenehm. Vielleicht machen wir es wie bei Wetten das. Da gab es doch auch immer so eine Sommerausgabe. Dann müssten wir das mal schauen.
Genau, Sommersalor in Barcelona.
Irgendwie sowas. Ja, das wäre es.
Das wäre nicht gut.
Wir denken mal darüber nach. Jedenfalls, das sind genau die richtigen Worte. Und ich finde das skandalös, dass Merz sich nicht hinter Petros Anschluss gestellt hat. Dass der dann im Weißen Haus sitzt und quasi das Anschluss in den Rücken fällt, weil Trump da so ein bisschen freiträgt. Da muss man schon auch sehen, wenn man dort sitzt, dann vertritt man Europa und dann muss man gerade hier das sehr ernst nehmen, wenn da ein großes und auch wichtiges Land wie Spanien sich völlig korrekt äußert. Das ist ja nicht irgendwas Verrücktes, sondern völlig korrekt geäußert.
Macron hat sich ein bisschen ähnlich geäußert. Und Hans Hüt, dessen Meinung ich ja sehr schätze und der auch sehr viel Erfahrung in Kommentierung von solchen Sachen hat, meinte, das wird März und Macron endgültig zur Rütten. Und ich denke mir, das wird stimmen. Und Macron steht aber auf der richtigen Seite.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es weitergeht. Wir haben ja jetzt einen Salon vor uns, der zwei geteilt ist zum ersten Mal. Das liegt daran, dass wir über das Buch von Ulrike Herrmann, zwei jetzt gleich auch, sprechen. Wir nehmen da etwas auf, aber wir können das erst in einer Woche veröffentlichen zum Book Release. Also wir sprechen über Geld als Waffe. Das ist das lange erwartete Buch, jedenfalls für viele. Und darüber müssen wir diskutieren. Also sie spricht über Kriegswirtschaft, über das, was für Aufrüstung getan werden muss. Sie beschäftigt sich stark mit China und Russland und unsere Rolle in diesem Spiel. Und wir haben aber noch ein zweites Buch, über das wir im Salon sprechen. Und das veröffentlichen wir jetzt schon. Wir haben uns etwas zweites ausgebucht. Auf deinen Wunsch, muss ich sagen. Ich hatte ja nur die Clips mitgebracht aus dem Ben Podcast mit Bibi Bianca Heinicke. Und du hattest gesagt, das wäre doch eigentlich ein Buch, über das wir sprechen können.
Ich dachte, sie redet ja nur Blödsinn. Und typischerweise sind ja die Leute im nicht spontanen Gespräch, sondern in der Bücherpublikation etwas klüger. Das wollte ich einfach kurz überprüfen.
Ja, ich habe das auch überprüft. Aber ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob die Eingangsthese stimmt. Wie man Geschichte schreibt, denn dein Leben verändert die Welt. So heißt dieses Buch. Ich habe es tatsächlich sehr schnell, aber ich habe es durchgelesen. Du bist da nochmal anders rangegangen. Das wirst du uns gleich erzählen. Ich habe tatsächlich bei der Lektüre gedacht, eigentlich wäre es ideal, wir machen ein Bühnenprogramm draus und reisen damit durch die Lande, lesen das in verteilten Rollen. Ich glaube, das wäre Comedy Gold. Aber wir fangen jetzt erst mal damit an, dass wir über dieses Buch reden. Und vielleicht gibt es auch das eine oder andere Learning für unser Publikum. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Jedenfalls sehen wir jetzt eine neue Personality oder eine alte Personality möglicherweise. Und da ist gar nicht so viel Neues da. Also wir erforschen, dass ich von Bibi und von uns selbst sicherlich auch mal Konsumkritik, fast Kapitalismuskritik, nur Konsumkritik.
Folgender Teaser. Wolfgang hat ja ein sehr kritisches Buch geschrieben über Influencer. Und das ist auch ein sehr kritisches Buch. Vielleicht passt es doch besser und dann muss man hinten rüber, weil sich doch am Kopf kratzen.
Vielleicht kann man auch mit den Verlagen reden, dass man es zusammen rausgibt als Paket. Wir denken da nah. Da gibt es noch viele Möglichkeiten. Was habe ich noch dabei? Ich habe einmal noch ein Update zu den indischen Studenten in Deutschland. Denen wurde ja schon das Leben schwer gemacht. Jetzt sollen sie sogar noch ausreisen. Hunderte von ihnen, ehe sie einen Studienabschluss haben. Wir sprechen kurz über einen Artikel aus dem Telegraph, über die Situation in der iranischen Zivilbevölkerung. Ich habe ein grandioses neues Klassikalbum dabei. Mein Lieblingsstreichquartett Leon Kuro hat geliefert. Endlich eine neue CD. Dann werfen wir einen psychoanalytischen Blick auf unsere Gegenwart. Also was leugnen wir und was verleugnen wir? Wie müssen wir Trump nochmal anders sehen? Was genießen wir eigentlich, wenn wir Trump sehen? Auch da geht es zum Beispiel um Trump bei der Kirk-Trauerfeier. Was passiert da eigentlich, wenn er sagt, aber sorry, ich hasse meine Gegner? Und er hat das so ganz klar ausgesprochen. Alenka Zupančič, aus dem Slavojšiček-Umfeld.
Ja, das dachte ich mir schon.
Ja, du hast es dir gedacht. Sie legt dir ein Buch vor, das heißt Das Ende, mit einzelnen Texten, die ja vom Ende handeln. Vom Ende oder von den Enden, muss man sagen. Und ich habe den Debüt-Roman gelesen von Hiroko Oyamada. Da hatten wir schon mal das Buch von ihr, Das Loch. Und jetzt kommt heraus Die Fabrik.
Sehr gut. Ich ergänze mit Carla Hinrichs. Das Buch ist da. Sie ist angeklagt wegen Redelsführerin einer kriminellen Vereinigung. Hier werden also Jahrhunderte alte Terrorparagrafen wieder angewandt. Das müssen wir uns mal anschauen. Außerseben habe ich sie ja vor zwei Jahren in meinem Fernsehpodcast, habe ich den Fernseh- oder den, wie nennt man es? Fernsehmoment des Jahres ausgewählt, weil sie bei Anne Will saß. Und dort die Frage aufkam, aber Frau Hinrichs, können sie nicht ein bisschen konstruktiver Kampagne machen und protestieren? Und dann fragte sie nur zurück, haben sie eine Idee? Und Anne Will so, ich? Nein? Also wirklich grandios. Und das wird auch ausführlich beschrieben. Plus natürlich diese ganzen Gerichtsprozesse, die laufen. Dann zwei Texte, Pascal Reinhardt also. Ich hatte es ja angekündigt. Er fragt sich, ob uns die Milliardäre nicht unendlich leid tun sollten. Und haben wir nicht dieses Apps, die ein Problem, solange wir Milliardäre haben? Einfach, weil das strukturell eingeprägt ist. Er gibt eine sehr psychologische Antwort. Also klar, jetzt mit Hegel als Anlauf, aber dann vor allem Lakan, das Begehren und so weiter. Ich halte das für sehr schlüssig argumentiert, aber ich denke, es steckt soziologisch noch mehr drin. Also nehme ich das selber wieder als Anlass, um dann später mal drüber zu schreiben. Und die New York Times Vivienne Wang fragt sich, wo sind eigentlich in China die AI-Doomers? Denn in Amerika fällt das doch jetzt eins zu zwei aus und die Leute freuen sich gar nicht auf die Zukunft, die mit KI kommen. Und China hat es wohl irgendwie hinbekommen, eine KI Gegenwart zu schaffen, bei der tatsächlich staatliches Vertrauen sich als KI-Vertrauen vererbt. Also ein sehr interessantes Konstrukt, das natürlich nur mit autokratischen Mitteln und so weiter. Aber es schlägt sich am Ende doch nieder und das schauen wir uns kurz an.
Das alles kann man dann hören im Salon. Also der erste Teil mit Bibi und diesen Empfehlungen erscheint dann jetzt sofort. Und der zweite Teil, da sprechen wir ausführlich über Geld als Waffe von Ulrike Herrmann. Das erscheint dann in etwa einer Woche. Das alles kann man hören, wenn man den Salon abonniert. Man geht am besten auf die wunderschönen von Stefan, Claude und vielen weiteren Akteuren gestalteten Homepage neuezwanziger.de. Dort kommt man gleich zum Salon. Man kann den Salon buchen über Apple, über Patreon und Steady. Bei Apple geht das gleich in der App, wenn man darüber Podcast hört. Wir empfehlen wie gesagt Steady. Das ist sehr einfach und der Zugang ist ganz leicht. Ich will nur noch auf drei Termine kurz hinweisen. Ich bin am 10.3. in Idar-Oberstein, am 11.3. in Duisburg und am 26.3. in Hamburg. Alle genauen Infos stehen auf meiner Homepage.
Idar-Oberstein?
Ja.
Woher kennt man das?
Von den Edelsteinen.
Den Edelsteinen.
Ja.
Das klingt nach Bayern oder so.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist Rheinland-Pfalz.
Rheinland-Pfalz, na gut.
Es geht um Heimat dort.
Das dachte ich mir. Genau so klingt das nämlich.
Ja. Gut, dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon mit Bibi. Ja.